Wow
some people were telling me that I
wanted to die then I should come here
and the impression I had before coming
was that it was complete chaos I thought
I'd get kidnapped at the airport and I
thought I'd see pirates
it feels like no-man's land
you always feel gridlocked because you
know you just want to walk in a straight
line and not know where you'll end up
but here it's always clear where you'll
end up psychologically it can be tough
they will have allowed a civil war
90k beloved a technology so PA you do
this Russia de continually hey Baba we
had to be the puja after Appa Don - Appa
Don hemmed in the walk-in
Talia al Ghul but he look with me with
his away and now hate one today in an
intervention for social media had the so
line like a massive tirado why I tie it
up a Silurian about we are hunted like a
log let's go honeymoon the toy can
earning a little back away and I can do
Tanika behind why my tablet over shit
absorb really good man
oh hey honey I am missing my I got so
many honker winning I'm seeing so I'll
go ahead and I'm gonna hand off a beggar
so I live online what has just one who
played again a couple brain handshake
and this a pataga we are on what
happened boy see the wall cover you
we have a couple per se acaba Oaxaca
City chic I imagine to be very busy and
to the vibrant and I imagine that the
old Ottoman houses that are crumbling
and people just going about their
business
I'm sure it's it's a really but far more
vibrant than my with we're saying which
feels more like a prison in a way
haha mezquia Noir and selected a diverse
collection airtight with adidas 100 and
Nevada Butler absalom busy do I have the
governor and speciality in the Emerson
sit up and pay any local mother univocal
am seen in NASA see an officer Lana
had the towel and center button in our
kitchen a good core no fishy
dramatically and Cienega Lana reckons
it's a long life
Norma and off to you know the Madonna
often on the manna Obama and Senator
Rockefeller a type of the suburban en
Anaya along the mushiya and had an sleep
at a walk or play with the garlic
a woman who did observer I think and
believe on cause it to go Angela that's
example middle here I don't like the
idea of setting myself apart personally
from the local community and traveling
and visibly armed with vehicles I know
it's necessary from a security point of
view but I personally don't like doing
that because it creates such a gap
between me and just look at the locals
and I think that it breaks trust the
UN's a target you know and the people
running this mission working on a very
political issue so they know that they
could be attacked
Alya pull off to our calendar innovation
is key to start Oh Somali that's article
dombay Advil or absent Allah and you can
forget they were Sonia I come to
harmlessly over can follow the link Eska
Agassi like Hal Anil a zero I'm so much
fitter illness vigil I wish to gain of
internal Cupido coumadin mother high
just to live eternally Atlanta hello
Camille Duty Old Market am I good
natural selection is rejection of
Moroccan society good Lord or legality
yeah
hey go on my bar Elena diesel Cassady
boy El Campo definitely a sauna hello ah
- you know my uncle I see Melinda our
Bureau at the Malayan October of the
Mojo
AHA's Mariah deport an idea so bhai
omakase IOC didn't either was new
current no naka tomorrow not the pasta
Grisha Jeroboam total official Reza
no edema Christy Romer Omar Lego Cuusoo
callamezzo Monterey Castle okay so Colin
Slade elixir LL Cool Adria O'Donnell a
serene DC Monte Casa Kelly your
bronchial casket a Cola drink easier to
say a Gurkha to dream Cara you're always
aware that you'll cut off some that
there's only so much you can experience
for me this isn't this is the way people
should live it's just the way in which
to survive the door IDenticard or wasn't
gonna move again I finally lands on my
luck that's where we do them been
overdoing forgotten Amedeo oh look at
that
Sakura inaudible